there is no best thing to do in life
anything that you take up and if you put
your heart and soul into it it becomes a
great thing if you want to be in a
competitive situation the thing is you
have to work on your competence what
worked for one person we try to make it
work for another person and destroy the
person completely unfortunately this is
labeled as education need motivation
watch atop tenant believe nation what's
up at seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out onto the world so let's
get your motivation to attend and get
you believing in you grab a snack on
chewing today's lessons from a man who
went from moving around a lot as a kid
and having a passion for motorcycles and
travel to then having a spiritual
experience then he decided to dedicate
his life to spirituality and starting
the Isha Foundation he sadguru and
here's my take on his top ten girls a
success vol 3 joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one be passionate about
everything there are no right things to
do in life if you choose something and
put everything that you have into it
it'll become a great thing is it the
right thing is it the best thing when
you say is it the right thing what
you're asking is is it the best thing to
do in life there is no best thing to do
in life anything that you take up and if
you put your heart and soul into it it
becomes a great thing this is the best
thing No
then what is the best thing there is no
such thing don't look at yourself as a
delhi 8 or an idiot whatever you want to
call yourself if you're just a piece of
life hmm hello and today you're here one
day you'll be poop dong you are a brief
life I want you to just imagine you've
seen those insects which come when it
rains you know and switch fly
suppose you are that you just came alive
dong that's what you are just compared
to the span of your life the insects
life is looking so meaningless and poop
and gone that's what the rivers are
thinking about you poopoo cupen gone yes
or no
compared to their lifespan you are just
like that insect or less than an insect
isn't it so I am NOT somebody who ever
debated he is this the right thing to do
in my life what was needed I jumped into
it because if you are a constipated life
you will always be thinking about what
to do what not to do what to do what not
to do what is my passion what is not my
passion why the hell are you not
passionate about everything
hello why are you not passionate about
everything in the existence you're only
passionate about one thing means what
you constipated that's what it means
idiots do things that they don't like to
do suffer for their whole life because
they think it's needed or they think
it's their duty intelligent people do
what they love to do they enjoy their
life to some extent but a genius learns
to do what is needed joyfully that's
when your genius flowers because it's no
more about you now there's a limitless
way of looking at life rule number two
be well managed if you try to control
the variety of situations that may pop
up in your face tomorrow morning all
that will happen is you will become a
very limited life you would step out
into the world and do whatever that
needs to be done only if you have an
assurance no matter what you walk into
you will not lose yourself you will walk
full stride otherwise you'll only be a
half a step most human beings are half
steps because the fear of suffering if
this happens what will happen to me if
that happens what will happen to me if
you're well managed within yourself you
know how to manage your thought you know
how to manage your emotion you know how
to manage your body your chemistry your
energy if you know how to manage all
this what does it matter if you walk
into hell I'm asking if you are well
managed if you are a heaven within you
what does it matter where you go hell
also will be an interesting place to go
but if you are ill managed then you want
to be in a nice place all the time you
will not step out into anything I am NOT
saying this is wrong
this is against nature because in nature
every life is aspiring to a B as much as
it can be
isn't it every life is naturally
aspiring this is not a philosophy this
is not an ideology but you must do this
or that it is natural and intrinsic for
every life that you will do as much as
it can from an earthworm from a worm to
an insect to a bird to an animal to a
tree every one of them are trying to be
full-fledged life if you go against this
simply because of the fear of suffering
then all possibilities of exploring the
nature of being human the tremendous
immensity of being human
is just lost upon humanity today you
will see this everywhere when people say
I am only human they are talking about
the limitations of being human they are
not talking about the possibilities of
being human isn't it when if we are the
most intelligent species on the planet
if we are the most capable species on
the planet should we be talking about
our possibilities or should we be
talking about our limitations whenever
anybody writes or says oh we are human
they are always referring to their
limitations never to the possibilities
of being human this is because the the
most fundamental things have not been
taught in our education systems how to
handle your thought and your emotion
your psychological drama has gone out of
control it's a badly directed drama
believe me if we choose a well-directed
drama you would take it to the
conclusion that you want isn't it
because it's a badly directed drama just
about anybody can take charge of it who
is the director of your psychological
drama just about anybody isn't it
anybody can make it into your tragedy
rule number three build your competence
competition is a good thing
if you are incompetent and you're in
competition you will feel stressed
if you want to be in a competitive
situation the thing is you have to work
on your competence right now the problem
is you're tweaking your desire you're
not tweaking your competence this is
what has to happen that we must teach
children to tweak their competence not
their desire we are calling this
ambition we calling this goal oriented
Ness ambition means what you tweaked up
your desire you will suffer invariably
if you tweak up your competence you will
see wherever you go you are doing better
than what people expect you to so
naturally
things will go well for you competition
is not the bad thing lack of competence
is the bad thing so instead of
competence we have big desires
if you focus enough on enhancing your
competence you will see there is such
joy in breaking limitations every day
and becoming something better you don't
care a damn how somebody else is doing
rule number four prioritize suppose
let's say you have to cook something
that's a you have to bake a cake or you
want to cook some rice you turn on this
Tao
turn off this tau 10 understand turn off
this tap it's a long process
and of course they know won't happen so
this is the story of majority of the
spiritual seekers there off and on and
off and on and off and on Oh does it
mean to say I must be only here there
that's not it
the priority should not shift the
priority is set slowly everything with
the new will slowly organize itself in
that direction because the priority is
shifting this life does not know which
way to go
it is confused every two minutes if you
change the destination on the GPS for
sure it does not know where to go
isn't it so this is what is happening
and for in most people this is why a
spiritual path seems to be order is long
impossible unattainable all these things
simply because people are shifting
priorities all the time rule number five
my personal favorite ride the wave of
life is it true that every other
creature on this planet a worm an insect
a bird and animal with a millionth of
our brain they're conducting their life
process quite well hello
okay when I say live process we are born
they're born just like that we grew up
they grow up we make a living they make
a living we may reproduce they reproduce
we do all this with enormous fuss they
simply do it yes or no every simple
thing we're doing it enormous fuss they
are simply doing it different various
processes of life and death they are
doing it without fuss we are doing
everything with great fuss is this a
sign of highest level of intelligence
I'm asking we are supposed to be the
most intelligent and there is no
question that we have the most evolved
neurological process on the planet yes
we have the most evolved neurological
system that we must be able to sense and
feel and experience and perceive
understand and express things in the
highest possible way but no other
creature on the planet is struggling
like the human creature right now this
is simply because you have been given a
super supercomputer do you agree with me
that this is the most sophisticated
gadget on the planet not the iPhone the
eye
but now the question is have you read
the user's manual that's all people have
not read the user's manual for the most
complex machine on the planet and
somehow blundering through somehow
trying to use it everything is a problem
tell me one thing that human beings are
not suffering if they're poor they
suffer their poverty you make them rich
they suffer the taxes if they're not
educated they suffer that put them to
school lot of suffering not married they
suffer that get them married I didn't
say anything I didn't say a thing
okay no children some people suffer that
children daily suffering so you seem to
be suffering every aspect of life so if
you offer death will you go do I fully
know you will suffer that so tell me one
thing that we are not suffering now
people we vilasa fees life is suffering
no no life is not suffering nor is it a
joy it's simply there it's a phenomena
if you write it it feels fantastic if
you're crushed by it it feels terrible
so are you riding the wave of life or
are you being crushed by it that's all
the question is rule number six be
interested in people I say this just a
couple of weeks ago I was in
conversation with someone who is
considered some kind of an expert on
Internet affairs and social media and
all this so he's been looking at our
material in the YouTube and various
other platforms and I said me easily I
can give you 50 times more than what is
there you know just people work on all
the thousands of hours of audio and
video that's there in the archive 50
times more in a year's time we can
multiplied by 50 that much material is
there he said Satguru already what is
there here you're throwing it all over
the place it's worth a billion dollars
I said see what will I do with the
billion dollars my interest is seven
billion people I have no interest in
billion dollars what do I do with it
my interest is people rule number seven
strive for a better life as a generation
if you create a huge amount of positives
a negative will become small if you
create huge amount of negatives they
will become big and positive will become
small this whole life is there has never
been a point any time and there never
will be where everything is perfect okay
there's no such thing because life is a
possibility because it's a possibility
it cannot be perfect doesn't matter what
we do is still something more to do
always that is why it's an endless
possibility striving does not mean I
want to be a good man I want to be a
good man she being morally good he's
only good for the society not good for
the human being yes if you are morally
correct it's good for people around you
because you contained but it's not good
for this life
so this life needs a little different
kind of nurture in that context how many
people in this world are going to stop
before you and may fall dead how many
people in how many people will be set
the seed that they will be striving to
be a better life than the way they are
right now
a little higher expression of life this
is all your focus should be rule number
eight don't pass on bad things the
Japanese people eat much less fat than
the Americans and the British because of
this people believe they have
much less incidence of cardiac arrests
less people in Japan die of heart
failures and heart attacks than they do
in UK and in United States but the
French eat a lot more fat but still they
have much less incidence of cardiac
problems compared to the British and the
Americans the Japanese people don't
drink much wine so they have much less
cardiac problems but the Italians drink
only wine and they also have much less
cardiac problems than the English and
Americans so the deduction is it is the
English language which is the problem
[Applause]
thing was speaking which is the problem
so this has been a problem everywhere
that we try to transplant what is
happening in one place simply as it is
in another place not just geographically
and culturally even from individual to
individual that what worked for one
person we try to make it work for
another person and destroy the person
completely and fortunately this is
labeled as education mass producing
people though we are a mass of people on
this planet a huge number over 7 billion
people stealing you were produced
individually not mass-produced are you
right from my childhood I've been
noticing this that most adults want to
teach something when they see children
all those damn things which have not
worked in their life this is one wow you
have to take with me
that is from this moment onwards in your
life
you will not pass on anything that is
not worked for you to anybody else hello
even if you cannot pass on the best
things to other people at least what is
not worked for you you don't give it to
anybody will you do this does anger work
for you so don't give it to anybody
does misery work for you this depression
work for you so if you are angry if
you're depressed you're miserable just
shut up okay and sit in one place and
handle it
rule number nine don't try to be
intuitive people start developing these
things for everything when their logic
fails they will think that you know you
want to do something you don't know how
to do it you're not sure whether to do
it or not do it then the simple solution
they're taking is okay this finger is
this this finger is this yes no give it
to the child if he holds this yes if he
holds this not this is not into your
laugh Allah no I will come to you I am
NOT I am going more basic the answer is
not just about you I'm just using it now
this is just that your logic has become
you know incapable its collapsed unable
to come to your logical decision so you
are succumbing to this simple way if
some child holds your hand like this or
like this yes or no anyway when there
are two options 50% of the time you
could be right yes being 50% of the time
right is not good enough isn't it yes
isn't it so I was you know some time ago
I was visiting a a homeopathic doctor
there in his clinic they put up an ad
some homeopathic medicine which will
work for all kinds of snakebites you're
living in Bombay proverb probably it's
not easy for you where I come from
snakes are everywhere on a daily basis
so I looked at this and then I asked him
how come this medicine you are
advertising that it works for all kinds
of snake bites because if you are not
already aware of this snake bites are
fundamentally
two kinds one type of venom attacks your
cardiovascular system another kind of
venom attacks your nervous system the
two completely different kind of
chemicals and it works upon your system
in a different way
generally for both you have different
types of antidotes but for everything
this particular medicine is supposed to
work how is that possible so the doctor
said see in India 90% of the Indian
snakes have non poisonous so 90% of the
time it works that's not good enough
isn't it if the remaining 10% which is
crucial isn't it so
intuition don't get into this thing
about you trying to be intuitive
never try to intuitive logic is
dependable isn't it there are moments
when there is certain clarity which has
no logical explanation at that time it's
okay but you'll never try to be
intuitive if you try to be intuitive
your logical mind will become deceptive
and come to all kinds of stupid
decisions you'll get certainly guidance
voices from the heaven you know all
kinds of voices people are hearing logic
is dependable go by it at least you
won't make a fool of yourself and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is get into nature if
you can find a place where there are no
sounds of machines and your cell phone
will not think think quietly if you can
listen to the sound of the trace the
breeze the water just the natural sounds
if you pay enough attention tremendous
things will happen to you
many times have been in the south engine
you know they're kind of tropical
rainforest the longest I've been there
through the jungle for about 23 days
alone no any kind of support no
cellphone for sure those days then not
even a torchlight and fourth day I ran
out of the food that I was carrying so I
lived off the forest man Bob ate today I
lost my jacket and one half of my shirt
because I was chased by some animals in
by that whole thing I had half a shirt
and pants and I walked through ice this
is elephant country tiger country iso
tigers panthers elephants all kinds of
the wild buffalo various kinds of
animals very close quarters but
at the end of it when you look back what
is the biggest impact on you
it's the insects it's in the nights the
orchestra that goes on in the rainforest
it's unbelievable and the timing every
day not 2:15 means one group will stop
and another group will start really the
sense of time every day exactly by the
second one group will start another
group will start you don't know what
they're talking about they're definitely
talking something that you don't know
for sure they're not just making dumb
noises so if you just sit there and
listen and listen and listen and listen
Roli you start noticing there is a
pattern and an organization to this
which is far bigger than any human
symphonies that you can achieve far more
complex and far more intense I think
it's very important for every human
being particularly if you have children
vacation need not be Disneyland I'm not
against it but one trip is enough all
silly stuff which excites you
vacation should be into nature if you
can take your children walk in a jungle
not in a result just live in a mountain
expose them to nature I will tell you
you will bring up your children not only
physically healthy mentally healthy far
more sensible and accepting and
wonderful kind of human beings if they
know how to because once you go into
nature whose son you are whose daughter
you are what are you in the city doesn't
matter okay it's very important that
everybody experiences that otherwise you
start creating your own illusions as to
who you are and you start believing it
for sure
now I've got a very special sadguru
bonus clip on how to stop raising the
bar of survival but before that I want
to know what did you learn from this
clip what did you learn from these video
hoes
what did you learn from Sadhguru today
that you're going to somehow apply to
your life or to your business please
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
loved see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
let's say taking United States as an
example this is not going to be the
problem of only United States United
States has come first in the race okay
others will get it because they're all
going the same way right now u.s. is a
stop example one thing is we go on
raising the bar for survival we must
define this is survival this means
you're good enough after this it must be
exploration of what you really wish to
do but we keep on raising the bar of
survival in such a way now even after
becoming the most affluent nation a
whole lot of people are just struggling
for survival this is senseless an
affluence affluence means your survival
is done thing isn't it but like you just
mentioned there is working three jobs to
survive this is not affluence this is
horrible poverty at least in India we
can sit back and enjoy
see the way we have structured the
society right now is people have a 35
year house mortgage I mean if you have a
35 year economic commitment to something
tomorrow even if God popped up here you
can't change the direction of your life
because the bank is here what will you
do because largely you're all from
Christian community so I am saying if
Jesus popped up tomorrow and he says
come follow me
you're not going because we got monthly
payment you got bills to pay
insurance to pay you can't change this
is a silly way of organizing our lives
the question the very reason why we want
to become affluent is so that depending
upon what Life offers us we can change
the direction of our life whenever we
want isn't it
isn't it very important this is one
thing that has to sink into the American
people being the most affluent nation
means you are not battling for survival
this is happening because you are
raising the bar of survival endlessly no
matter what you do you're still only
fighting for survival if this one thing
we change then we can do lot of things
about health and well-being and beyond
that raise your standard Apple at the
core is core value is that that people
passion
[Music]
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's suppose to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten gross a success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual Clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in the description for
details